here's an interesting story from the New
York Times one afternoon in late
September hundreds of students at Timber
Creek High School in Orlando poured into
the campus's sprawling Central Courtyard
to hang out and eat lunch for members of
an extremely online generation their
activities were decidedly analog dozens
sat in small groups animatedly talking
with one another others played pickle
ball or makeshift lunchtime courts there
was not a cell phone in sight and that
was no accident in May Florida passed a
law requiring public school districts to
impose rules bar ing student cell phone
use during the class time this fall
Orange County Public Schools which
includes Timber Creek High went even
further barring students from using cell
phones during the entire day in
interviews a doz in interviews a dozen
Orange County parents and students all
said they supported the no phone uh
rules during class but they objected to
their District's stricter dayong ban
parents said their children should be
able to contact them directly during
free periods while students describe the
all day ban as unfair and infantilizing
Sophia Ferrara the 12th grader at Timber
Creek um who needs to use mobile devices
during free periods to take online
college classes says they expect us to
take responsibility for their own
choices for our own choices but then
they are taking away the the ability for
us to make a choice and to learn
responsibility and then there were other
uh protests and so on uh continue says
other students said schools seem more
prison-like without their phones to call
their parents they noted students must
now go to the front office and ask
permission to use the phone surve also
has also intensified to enforce the ban
ly Lake a Timber Creek security officer
now patrols Lunch Period on a golf cart
nabbing students violating the ban and
driving them to the front office where
they must Place their phones in a locked
cabinet for the rest of the day Orange
County students describ the ban as
regressive noting that they could no
longer use their phones to check their
class schedules during school take
photos of their projects and art class
find their friends at lunch or even add
the phone numbers of their new
classmates to their contact list 13
Catalina and e8th grader at a local
Middle School said imagine that the
device you use on a daily basis to
communicate with other people is
completely gone it feels completely
isolating okay
um the only
thing well I'm not going to say it's
surprising but the only thing notable
about something like this is that this
is not already the policy in every
school in the
country you know it it's it's it is
insane in fact that a school comp
completely Banning cell phones in in
school entirely that this is such a
notable exception that it gets an entire
New York Times article about it that's
how notable it
is which I guess shows how naive I am
because I gotta say I I am actually
surprised by that I I sort of uh as you
know my kids don't go to public
school I guess I figured that most
schools already had a policy that you
can't have phones in school at all and
then you know most kids a lot of kids
ignore it that that's what I figured I
figured that the kids that are on the
phone at school and I know that many are
but I figure they were breaking the
rules in doing
that come to find out that um apparently
it's extremely rare for a school to say
you cannot have phones here at all
during school
hours which is
again it's just
crazy
and
it creates an impossible situation is it
any
surprise that we have so many kids who
are graduating without having learned
anything you know we played the video
several days ago of the the teacher I
think she was I think it was a seventh
grade teacher talking about how kids are
so far behind they're delayed you know
he's got kids in his uh class who are on
a third grade reading level and many
different factors are blamed on that
people talk about the the the lockdowns
Co lockdowns that had something to do
with it and there are there are many
factors that go into
it but this right here is like the main
factor okay if you want to know why
there are so many kids who are not
learning at school it's because they all
have phones and they're on their phones
the whole time they are in they are
totally distracted the entire time while
they're at school through their through
for many of them their entire uh
experience in great
school and it's just it's not possible
to teach
them you know that I can be plenty
critical of public school teachers and
for good reason but I also sympathize
with them for for uh for many reasons as
well and this and and here is one like
what are you supposed to do as a public
school
teacher if the school has not banned
phones you're competing how could you
can't compete now you're competing
constantly for the kids it's hard you
back in the dark old days when cell
phones didn't exist at least smartphones
didn't exist and uh which is most of my
time in public school that was the case
and back then it was it was hard enough
for the teachers to get the kids
attention because there are many other
things you can be distracted
by but at least everybody was present in
the room with you like everyone's
sitting in the room physically and yeah
they might be distracted because they're
writing notes passing notes along or
they're goofing off with their friends
or something but everything is like all
the distra actions at least are located
in the room with you and now these
teachers are competing with the whole
world outside because these kids are
have their eyes glued uh on this to this
portal that takes them
out into the into the digital
world and so the teachers are competing
with like the entire universe to get the
kids attention and it's impossible it is
impossible this is what what it comes
it's not overstating the case well if
you didn't already know P talk is
planning to alleviate $10 million in
veteran debt by Veterans Day they'll get
there by giving a portion of every new
order to this cause with just two weeks
ago Pure Talk is 74% of the way there
but they still need your support think
about this the US military is made up of
100% volunteers these are men and women
who willingly sacrifice everything they
have for this country when they're done
serving their uh they return home to a
tight job market and outrageous living
expenses that's why I'm so happy a
private company like P has jumped in to
help when you switch to P Talk's
Lightning Fast 5G Network they'll donate
a portion of every new order uh to this
noble cause you can make a real
difference just by choosing Superior
cell phone service P talks plans start
at just 20 bucks a month offering
unlimited talk text more data and a
mobile Hotpot just go to Pur talk.com
Walsh and make the switch let's rally
together and show unwavering support for
our veterans visit Pur talk.com Walsh
and switch to pure talk today it's the
right move and it's the American way
that's Pur talk.com
today unless we
ban cell phones in every
school for the entire uh school day kids
are not going to learn you're just going
to see a total
collapse of the educational progress of
kids entirely this does not
work and we're seeing this is this is
the great experiment that is being run
right now because really Jen's just now
getting out of high school age they're
really the first generation that had
cell phones through their entire
childhood and let's take a look at them
and see how it's working out is it
working
out are we happy with the
progress do we feel like they graduated
high school and they're intelligent
well-rounded knowledgeable people in the
way that we want them to
be by and large does anyone feel that
way no it's a total
disaster
and unless we take what I guess seems
like drastic
measures
um unless we do that there's just
there's no hope for these
kids of course you have to ban and the
fact that you've got kids and I don't I
don't blame any of the kids in this uh
in their interviewed in the article I
don't blame them for being completely
attached to their phones it's how they
were
raised but when you have an eighth
grader saying uh that it's totally is ol
ating let me think about that for a
second she feels completely isolated if
she doesn't have her phone with her even
though she's in a classroom she she's in
a school with like hundreds of other
kids she's in a physical environment
surrounded by people including her peers
and yet she feels isolated if she
doesn't have her phone with
her
um now again that's not to criticize her
that's to critic ize the parents who
allowed her to develop that kind of
dependency on the
phone that without it it's like her it's
like a it's a you know for these kids
like a limb you know it's a part of them
and you take it away they don't know
what to do it feels like prison did not
have their phone for a few
hours which is all the more evidence
that they need to not have their phone
for a few hours in fact they shouldn't
have their phones at
all and I just can't believe some of
these parents that also object to taking
the phones away well how am I going to
get in touch with my
kid what there ask why what do you need
to call them five times a
day in fact you can get in touch with
them you can call what do you think
happened for for the entire history of
school up until the last few years what
do you think parents
did okay I went to school we didn't have
phones most of the time my parents
didn't need to get in touch with me
during this it's a very rare thing that
your that your parent actually needs to
get in touch with you during the school
day but if they needed to they could
call the front office that happens
sometimes they could drive to the school
where I am I mean there are ways to do
it it's not that
hard and if you really feel parents that
your kids need they need to have a phone
on them so that you can get in touch
with them at any moment because they
can't walk outside of your out of your
sight for a second without you being
able to immediately uh speak to them if
you really feel that way well then you
can get your kid a a a dumb phone you
can get your kid a flip phone that uh
you know and you can set it up so that
they can only call three numbers and
they can only text three numbers and
it's you and and Dad and whoever and a
sibling and you could do that those
kinds of phones exist they're pretty
cheap there's no reason and that that
solves that problem
completely and yet most of these parents
aren't doing that
they give their kids smartphones with
full internet access they send them to
school with those
phones and then they claim that they're
only doing it so that well I need to be
able to get just case my kid gets
kidnapped I need to be able to call
them well we know that's not the reason
because as I said there's a solution to
that you can get them a kind of phone
that doesn't have internet access can't
can't call and text but it can at least
call and text you and and that's it you
can do that every parent unless you're
an idiot you know that you can do that
you choose not
to
you have chosen to give your kid this
massive distraction you have
chosen to make sure that your kid uh
goes to school and is distracted every
second of every
day
it's it's insane it is
crazy and I know you've heard me say it
a million times but I I do just have to
remind you you know if you think that
it's impossible for a kid to function
without a
phone I'm here to to tell you it's not
my kids do none of my kids have phones
we are a very as I do this for a living
I work in media okay I we have to be
very plugged in and aware of what's
going on in the world it's not like
we're living off in the woods in the you
know it's not like we're living a 17th
century lifestyle as much as I maybe
would enjoy that if we were but we're
not and yet we managed to have kids that
don't have uh smartphones it is possible
to do it's very
possible if you like to see what else I
have to say you can access my full show
by going to dailywire.com or by going to
the Matt wall Show Twitter page hope to
see you there Godspeed